bro don't yeah we can't Happy House gets
a sore winner are winning that game with
[ __ ] vulgar vulgar doesn't play as
much as you
[Music]
all right so you want to do faster
response or no no no keep everything
else default no what have you are we not
doing heavy fine fine no no all right so
the people that need to accept mine by
our vulgar Griffin I think we're ready
to go - make sure you run - switch guns
we have to switch chat and just go to
games yeah we don't know just go to the
party and then click on your name and
switch every game Jeff yeah okay good
no but now I can't use my fusion rifle I
don't like no heavy who's going to
switch the game chat yeah in your party
party party all the way down at the
bottom party control party controls so
the bottle from the bottom now we here
is giving a party chat I got a certain
game transfer oh this is not good I
don't like to set up goddamnit
wait am I supposed to be a game Gentile
of listening well the only problem is we
want to hear people on the stream like
we want to hear it Griffin on the stream
right so Wilton bulgar let's go to game
chat Griffin this is gonna be this is
gonna be all you so they can hear you so
I'm just gonna stay where I am
yeah you just think can you hear me okay
all right stick stick with me just team
shots it'll be easier cuz it's to last
you just uh just just hear ya listen to
me when combat potential when we get
split up and they they stay together as
a team we don't want to rush them one
verse - yeah
oh you got me seasoned service revolver
yep where are you
yep just follow me don't touch that
shield no no but I think they're they're
outside I think they're leaning outside
yeah we got them all right it's you and
Griffin
yep just survived he's pushing you
I don't even engage the ship from grift
all right going around
don't don't land it don't even look he's
fast asleep
no no don't even puzzle it
I gotta rest up
they're just waiting yeah no it just
keep doing what you're doing they're
just they're they're buff [ __ ] each
other and they're [ __ ] just
hardscoping
shut them down you can only hear me
because it's I'm hosting it I'm hosting
the thing and oh we had to I can't wait
to see they had to leave so we all can't
hear each other I got just reaction
I got him
Griffin's will fall and push them
9 he got me into graviton he was way
back there now we're good we're good
just keep it tight
this dude is literally just laning with
graviton I love how he doesn't want to
use [ __ ] heavy but he literally uses
the meta and doesn't move
he's running nice bugger
[ __ ] graviton he's running
he's got hammers - just get your help
back he's gonna pop
yeah
he's gonna try
nice there it is now make him come to us
dude they're gonna play like [ __ ] you
in the lead
yep and come to us dude using graviton
they gotta get that rift let me go
fishing real quick let me just fish on
them is that fine
stay there don't it don't rush don't
rush keep playing the same five minutes
don't even [ __ ] with that he said he's
just trying to lane
they're coming right listen there oh no
you got the fishing
you got the fishing okay
[Music]
okay I'm going outside I'm trying to
beta I'll try to bait him outside I got
my golden yeah they didn't do it I'm
gonna use it to counter one of their
supers
you nearly dare fight on and claim
victory
nice Bolger to see
yeah user
her name John
[Music]
right let's do it longer
got me victory well-executed boom I go
back good [ __ ] [ __ ]
good listening it was good I go back to
party party chat all right yeah my
eighth is not gonna do the job that's
not bad though 25:19 so modest so who
plays Craig one by ten well I made a
good point why don't they why don't why
don't we play coke and they play hype
and Pikachu's and Sewer this no whoever
was second best yeah yeah what's that
map Kernan whoo-hoo-hoo replaying their
main flame you're playing height and
type and Pikachu is your teammate
I'm gonna send us a Nimba which I
managed to give us you gave me that
killed inch you hiked because you
related oh yeah yeah I was like I got a
fire I thought you could hear me and I
was like oh I just ran into you I was
thinking I would have to stop the game
because you were picking up heavy I was
like nope so who are we playing yeah
you're odd man out this game so then if
one of us look at is then we play you
guys I hope we get a rematch okay let's
you all right let's switch party chat
all right we switch and chair we're
supposed to the party check nobody cares
on the stream right yeah so Gavin Gavin
well they can hear you too in game chat
but they can hear us through party chat
because if Grif right so party only
party chat you can hear me right
oh so we need to stay on party chat but
what you could do kogas you could turn
my volume up when you leave then there
won't be an echo I think like if you're
in game chat well your games you turn my
volume up then you're big but hear me on
the stream I think I'm gonna switch the
game chat right now
yeah I'm just wishing the game chat I'm
gonna have to like one you think we're
gonna play again because well you guys
[Music]
next game yeah okay I'll dive against we
don't know yet
we're doing now nothing so we're just
waiting around Craig if they're not good
but he's gonna he's gonna butt-fuck gab
the entire time he's gonna be sitting
back with his [ __ ] vigilance so you
don't back up that was a good game it
was hey Grif can you zoom your camera
Craig's down you know zoom it you know
because we can see from your waist all
the way to the time of your guitar in a
round picture I don't know doesn't work
like that I wish you could just go to
the party and then and what nice Craig's
then yep
that's one right hollow on your
controller see my double square one
he's right they're gonna be up they went
up in the middle platform nice crowd I
don't think well he's using no mom so
he's got that devour so when you have
dad hurt and he runs away don't push him
he's gonna get his health back up top
blinky right sir trying to figure out
how you make you get ready supermarket
and abdomen left I got him
papi I'm gonna mute myself push all
[Music]
right I'm coming back come back to me
he's he's following me
okay right there
whoo watch that lien no rights I've got
yeah I guess you can't camera kind of
sucks oh you're dead already
no they they made it yeah
there's some people in chat making jokes
about you it's my laptop oh yeah no
[ __ ] can shut their face so they can do
yeah I don't know why it's showing me
talking it yeah he's gonna be waiting
yeah I don't know I'm going up top
here's that bang nice nice because he
does daffy really does most the work but
Craig will be sitting behind him that's
why like if you see gaff dip out you
know you know he's just sitting behind
the corner like waiting yep just like
that there you go
middle kneeling
the Craig popped up so much how do you
is there like cameras oh my god no there
isn't no I can hear you talking and it
shows that I'm talking yeah is there a
room on the table or would I be having
on to isolate a party yeah pains
oh they he blinked back he's in the
middle middle bridge he went to the left
I'm coming you what do you have like a
stack of books there anything yeah come
with me
Deb coming how to push on us behind us
let me backed off you with what time
riff riff he ran off all right yeah hype
I think they're bad let's switch to I
don't know at this point it really
doesn't matter man ah oh sure we're
gonna have to reset Corning I got my
stride I'll use mine first
I think maybe he can't hear him game
sound olive don't push up there logger
so there's chat settings in game that he
might have turned down or something
though he's slam
God wants us back and we play him I
don't I don't know man
good shake it shake all right so look
out he's gonna wait to use that know
about more clump or when you pop that
art yeah hey let's switch buddies
parties yeah [ __ ] don't even eat it
man what a [ __ ] as I was I'm sorry
that's what I'm saying well question
guys that's oh my god he does serious
Craig it's literally like on his dick
almost wish we had eggs I've seen many
parties you he's coming to sneak up on
the right backing off he's gonna cut me
off in the middle well that's the best I
can get from my camera people it is
better I just I got a gift real weapon
yeah that is your own capability that's
how you do it
[Music]
renewed good he biffed majorly he's
running he's gonna run
he's dead yeah I'm hurt I'm hurt too
but thumbs lips whatever XD nice oh no
you're good no we haven't used our
special no I did but I'm I'm getting
close I'm use yours when you can yeah
when you're good chest armor dear
oh I'm using sanguis no no how but
that's a good one you were strong
trigger do you want to push it before
you jump out there you don't it's not a
golden gun so no no another good one is
this notification boots because you kid
that wouldn't be very good in crucible
specifically these to be tears we would
not run on a Hanford but that's not the
problem if we can just depend on the
corner reload and come back it's knowing
where they are yeah I got that we came
started out Craig's with it
Craig's cheeks are always fun no don't
push don't do not push
he's got kill clip on that
get out there nice mr. cheeks
do the sanguine Alchemy's used to be
glitched where if you team shot and made
powerful Lord of Light
like the ones that refill was massive
trunks of you he's running his high oh
[ __ ] he's in the middle it's not
trending perk it was like a coding
glitch or something oh it wasn't
supposed to do there with me let him
push in I think it's 30 meters
really that's are you good with semen
stain cocky oh [ __ ] I'm so far with you
okay I'm go to your left okay Wow
all the way far corner calf and Josiah
kilt Fogarty to the wall I'm still
coming all right
you know they're running
Wow
still got this from so better three oh
the good smash it's close they're
blinking
all back fall back
all right gaps gotten over oh you got
watching this potato
there's nobody know if he's all why is
he so red because he's not healthy
Dizzy's fresh it's blood pressure high
blood pressure do you know you know he's
like hi Rick he's like an Irish precious
back Craig does play like a puss and
it's not Craig it's all gaps gap is the
one that's [ __ ] setting the
groundwork Craig just [ __ ] sits back
with a [ __ ] Metta weapon and spams it
he misses half his shots anyway Scotty
Craig I was watching that when he killed
you at the polls I need
outline do you like three times viewing
oh come on dad right there yeah I'm
watching the stream right now oh camon
either just kill coke what I thought
Gavin aider was the dude in the top
right that's titty f Rauf right there on
top right right side Craig your monster
with Uncle Adam got him don't let em
kill you
oh [ __ ] I couldn't run away I couldn't
run away you know what I think I'm on TV
announcer okay wait a minute
so now again we are winning that game
with [ __ ] vulgar and I love ogre
doesn't play as much
you're giving me crazy you got a double
kill which at one time but honestly I
even killed you with us when you had you
know what it wasn't bothered by your way
well don't leak the only thing that
bothers me [ __ ] because he was
listening to me he would raise I'm not
saying he did look the way he said it
for longer [ __ ] [ __ ] Craig Craig
Craig we were such a [ __ ] in this game
you are such a [ __ ] in this game when
it don't stay you play I wish you view
you have to have a door gasp and you
literally but fuck'em the entire gas is
moving the whole time and Craig is
literally like [ __ ] 10 yards behind
him just scoping with a [ __ ] facial
ensuite that's all you oh my god you're
gonna be salty all night tonight huh
he was teammate to die so he can get
[Music]
into a game
[Music]
and vulgar god I [ __ ] love how Craig
it's old [ __ ] close to you oh the closer
yes had a negative KD [ __ ] I'm still
yeah I've had a 2.03
2.83 you're such a [ __ ] [ __ ] hey gab
is good and it was slammed you took your
super away I know why yourself me you
take some square that game yeah super
you didn't take my super away
should I go Nova bomb that's if you're
super away well no you did so here it
just right now [ __ ] killed I'm
starting to lag in my hair baby am I
getting good internet those clothes
though okay maybe he doesn't want to
play with you right time crank crank
goes I'll take I'll take give because I
can't be honesty and you notice Frank
says that first you don't like no no I
love gas but like when I go okay you
were the first [ __ ] to go
you've got five people you got five
people you go I pee you need to some
water first
like that Craig you got it look like
you're gonna have a [ __ ] heart attack
I'm [ __ ] hydrated you know you notice
when it was supposed to be 1 verse 1
Craig goes we should do tubers - yeah it
says you suck and then wait for you to
show your heads so we can shoot it oh
you're right you're right the only thing
you do against me even comes close to
beating me is wait behind a corner and
job actually we did a one verse one game
and I [ __ ] spanked you even though
you're gonna say you might try
[Music]
no longer [ __ ] he's in the party bro
bro I was in good spirits I didn't even
start talking [ __ ] until Craig opened
his fat [ __ ] mouth that's the only
time yeah you know how cranky his wife
pranks are you got him so bad his wife
some scissors god she's like one she
wants attention so bad
[Laughter]
no I for the purposes I love Craig but
man when it comes to gaming and he talks
his nasally voice when he starts talking
I just
[Applause]
in the chat everybody yes
aren't you supposed to be in a different
party thing while we're doing this no
[ __ ] it you know because we for the chat
purposes I wanted to hear both you know
[ __ ] off hurt don't don't brush him
there's two of them I've got a little
grenade yeah you one little [ __ ] right
it's coming from the from the [ __ ] a
healing ribs hey that's part of the game
bro well I'm not supposed to use it as
part of the game what I'm supposed to
run a house that death is part of the
game what house just coming out of less
[ __ ] so much [ __ ] I know just shut
your little mini crazy ass right there
headshots galore yes I was on my screen
everybody look on my screen you'll see
that we've already had people say you
can't shoot broadside of a barn okay
outside of a bar your mom's ass they're
coming around
shooting me in the back up top down
below watch out oh oh so annoying bush
how do you think I feel I'm the one who
died so weak
come on Griffin were dead right there oh
he's dead now
oh well I was already down to nothing I
guess which guns no switch guns hold up
Oh was that rocket
fighting lion we're doing heavy snow now
it's fighting
see
this isn't gonna help but just out that
cash yeah almost County shooting
white-faced say I'm all the damn deaths
am i stuck behind a wall okay gun is
fighting
[Music]
what don't challenge does it get won't
be a challenge why god damn it oh my god
Trang oh you trying to do it man what
really is where I start using a not
using a [ __ ] all either usually luck
tracking what do you like it good team
power
so good thanks for saving my logo
something about he's dead gratifying
feeling let's just push on you in a row
oh my god I wanted to kill streak on
coke you need 10 he's gonna need an
inhaler behind us
whoo only the best hammers why did you
get them I need to get some well I
wasn't just throwing hammers and leased
him he's over where I just killed them
screw that
yeah look I came from behind
[Music]
[Music]
all right go back it is so bad cook I
bet we would have done good as a team we
won
and when I'm sorry I would not have been
fair don't worry man because we were
both carrying our team's not really
worried I got a lot I got a little bit
more grinding to do Oh like I said what
frustrates me is like Craig isn't better
like I don't think Craig's better than
really any of the people the worst fire
team but he does know like when it comes
to it he plays like a [ __ ] like he
knows how to just eat but hug somebody
who really from the heart paint brushes
gonna get skills yeah yeah she better
snot Gav's gameplay yeah that's it but I
got plays pretty good man he's really
good
I would say out of coax friends hypes
really good gas pretty good on one of
the ones I think air I think arrows
better than like you don't need those
probably where it kills it would
probably just assist
Craig watching your game this makes me
matter because you you literally do what
I just said
and I wish you'd be away then no I mean
I mean you dude you're so mean I know I
want to play him again I'm doing that I
sure can't do that I got I gotta go to
bed man hey crank cry sorry another get
another get another partner I want to
play tried another two verse hey I gotta
go wake up the buddy I got you
you guys you guys to be honest you guys
were come with the hardest team for us
because you guys pushed hard so that was
Craig I was tough for giggles like a
[ __ ] rap to you guys who we missing
we need Peaks and vulgar right no I
cannot play or or mean hi you me and I'm
gonna [ __ ] taking the whole thing to
guarantee oh that's a given oh no no no
Craig all I know is next time you never
ended yo ran these are perfect
we're gonna go random cuz if I can if
I'm you're gonna go with again you're
gonna go without our arrow
every time train your game plays hey you
think with any winning against me your
game play is the [ __ ] worst I watch
you I can see what gas doing around you
literally see gap run every blue like he
watches gap he doesn't even watch
anything else
he watches gap let's gap run and get all
the kills and then hope you better
support and I'm going to astray I
challenge what thing olive
oh you guys only lost once we don't yeah
we lose it all I get what they're saying
wasn't like what would they have to play
and then we have to get coke we have a
chance for Remus we already did that
no but not everybody did yeah but but
not us because we lost the last match so
then that means we play the person that
lost but least we didn't you guys know
in the beginning and played a game and
one yeah we all right so witnesses so so
we all we owe Bane and paints which
channel but we can't do tonight that's
AG not my champ yeah no babe you're back
with us cuz next time we do this random
[ __ ] teams
oh my god least you shut the [ __ ] up get
on no no come to the stream not for the
game [ __ ] up Craig I know we have the
behind-the-scenes meetings when he's
like join my parties cuz I don't want
any money oh and we're talking about
[ __ ] he has said you are dude what is he
one verse you and Craig well I want to
see let's go right now let's just play
dude I gotta go I gotta give Gripen in
the morning so we either player we don't
blame soda why don't you play it Peaks
[ __ ] my Internet's not is internet you
already let hype almost won us you guys
were late sitting down hey you guys
actually lied for Pikachu amen and a lie
baby man lie to win rather than sitting
behind it's not it's not we the way you
play you're not even one by himself
that's [ __ ] impressive all right I'll
give it to Gavin you still lost just
accept it
what what the hell was that
I do not die away cook you should still
be able to win with alder I almost did
[ __ ] accept that one game in which
gasps no vahanam I would know honestly
as Nova bomb here okay
we were actually up for a there to there
I couldn't Craig's by himself you could
that's what's supposed to happen dude
you're supposed to play coke and pretend
elimination and then Craig is I know
thanks Kevin Durant we could do a
rematch guys I'm a family want to go yes
do rematch guys but he does need gap
with the team that we be obviously would
be with Gavin that's kind of given dope
dope
well since--since vulgar is not in a
[ __ ] regular player and he's usually
not even playing how about me and height
versus you and [ __ ] you and gap you
confident with that no you're not not
even saying I'll play with right I don't
give a [ __ ]
I'll try to [ __ ] play [ __ ]
cuz get pissed me off to lost tonight
gab gab going he waits for people to
turn corners and I beat that
[ __ ] 1 verse 1 every single time
we played oh my god salty dude all
relaxed I'm not salty I'm just not even
concentrating now I mean the autopilot
open your hands right now stole my kill
I did
I sense pray for you come on there's no
heavy machinery
No thank you for getting that one
oh I know I know oh yeah all I did was I
forgot [ __ ] I don't have my team
we should have we won he's the chair I
want the last kill I remember I remember
that's fine so gab one you still lost
I'm lost
I missed except I'm impressed with gas
with
impressive he has three not even three
kills I think they might be a cyst
he's got three [ __ ] kills per double
elimination that's not how it works
we have to play Pope and we didn't look
at all the record you know
[Music]
[Laughter]
well Phoenix Phoenix we have to do we
have to do you and bulgar versus me and
Holly our chance to Craig hasn't had sex
in at least
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]